now I was just with your hubby last
night in Vegas yes I was just hanging
with him yes every one of the things he
told me that I thought was so amazing
not here tonight because he's doing a
charity event to raise money for the
Bahamas which was hit so hard last year
obviously with the hurricane so still in
desperate need of money and support
which is why we're doing the the charity
event tonight he told me to take care of
you because you were going to be on your
own but one of the things he said is hey
man boy shows there baby he did say you
right now are his creative inspiration
because you're doing things with the
prom that you haven't done since Moulin
Rouge singing dancing all this and that
you're really challenging yourself and
it's really awesome for him to watch I
feel completely I feel like he's my
inspiration because he actually is the
one that said to me baby just go for it
you can do it you can do it and when I
lose my confidence he'll prop me up
which is actually you know we all need
somebody like that in our lives whether
it's a parent or a partner so I'm just
very fortunate to have that I love that
your other besties just came up here to
[Applause]
see that bigger lies and bombshell
obviously she's gonna sit with you wait
I didn't I I don't even think about the
other one I just selfishly think about
my own
that's all I think about it as far as
I'm concerned she's money she's a new
chair yeah yeah yeah
[Music]